عندما كان المنظمون
ينتقدون خلفية قمة مجموعة الدول الصناعية السبع الكبرى ، ربما
كان من المفترض أن يثير شيء ما في المقدمة
الدهشة على وجه التحديد
، حيث دافع حاجب رئيس الوزراء الكندي
باستمرار عن
المصلحة الكندية وهو أن عطلًا في الحاجب المزيف والحاجب تسبب في
تصدع أحد
الناقدين يمكنني استخدام حاجبي ترودو القابل للإزالة
كطعم في المرة القادمة التي أذهب فيها للصيد
مازحًا ، شراب القيقب الآخر ليس مادة
لاصقة كافية للحواجب.
تمت مقارنة ترودو بالسيد.  رأس البطاطس مع السيد.
تتحدث حواجب البطاطا عن تعرضها للضرب ، قام
شخص ما باستبدال حواجب رئيس الوزراء
بتوقيعات دونالد ترامب
حيث نختلف قريبًا ، حيث كانت المخابئ
تتحقق من الحقائق وتحلل
بنية حاجب رئيس الوزراء بقاعدة
كثيفة كثيفة ، إنه لديه
حاجب غريب قام بالتغريد على أحد المدافعين الذين
ألقوا باللوم عليه.  الإضاءة لإلقاء الظلال
والإشارة إلى المزيد من الزوايا المباشرة التي
تبدو طبيعية ،
نلجأ إلى خبراء في فناني مكياج الحواجب المزيفة
الذين بدوا في حيرة من الفيديو
إذا كانوا يبدون ظلًا وهميًا ، شيء يستحق
أن يستمر ، لا أعرف ولكن بعد
أن أظهرناهم  التكوين
الطبيعي لحواجبه الآن ، ما رأيك هذا
الذي حواجبه في هذا الفيديو
حواجبه في كل سنواتهم
من وضع الماكياج والرموش الصناعية
، فنان الماكياج الذي تحدثنا إليه
لم أسمع أبدًا عن أي شخص يضع
حواجب زائفة على صانع الأخبار  عبر
أمريكا أنا جين ماوس